I've got just three months left to make
a success on my convict catering
business but the prison can't supply the
staff to monitor early-morning kitchen
shifts and my plan for a lunch delivery
service has proved impossible
they shouldn't underestimate the
difficulties in attempting to run that
kind of operation in a local jail to
give the business a long-term future I
now need to find a quality product I can
mass-produce without disrupting the
prison regime
- I think the answer has been right
under my nose the lemon treacle tarts
with trialed in local coffee shops are
fiddly to make and fragile to transport
so I've substituted delicate pastry for
a solid biscuit base and come up with a
bad boys bakery treacle slice so you've
got that solid biscuit base at the
bottom yeah treacle tart mix on top and
then we'll frost them well why are we
chose to mr. said it's a good question
I can get volume Antony hopefully if we
can start baking these in larger trays
we can produce larger volume okay look
at cutting this 2 4 6 8 20 portions it
compares to making 20 small tasks what's
the difference we're gonna do 500 eggs a
day
I'm barely fifty of those now that's
what a biscuit base tasting got a
softness
yeah it tastes good easy to produce yeah
my goal is to try and grab a piece of
the five billion pound UK coffee shop
market by persuading a major cafe chain
to stock a new product yeah here's my
problem to convince the prison not they
don't want him but they're uncertain and
they think you're still going down I'm
struggling personally we've all had the
issues I'm struggling with the system
the treacle slice is much easier to
produce than lunches so I won't need my
team in the kitchen at 6:00 a.m. but I
still need governor Edie Tillett and his
team to sign off on it
at Hawaii nice friendly cheery start in
the morning nice you know I've got a
tangible production kitchen that needs
to continue running there's individuals
in there now that have proven what
they're learning what they've grasped is
hope not just in terms of building their
confidence but how good they've become
over the last three months and the
potential in terms of business is huge
culture class because for us we've got
all the time in the world and the prison
you know prisons aren't doing time and
they got they got as much time as a
reason tomorrow's another day
what is new to us is actually getting
something that has to be done you know
by midday that day so I think that it's
probably new for us and that's probably
something we're going to have to try and
overcome it you know yeah it's not that
easy for us either how do you tell me as
you know I'm your [ __ ] I'll do anything
[Music]
[Laughter]
the authorities are beginning to
understand some flexibility is vital to
get the business working I'm hoping the
simplicity of producing one product the
slice will persuade edy to back me so
it's lemon curd treacle tart with a
really nice biscuit at the bottom
digestive biscuit looks like erred might
be a convert I mean what excites me
about this is it's a potential something
like that we just producing one product
and you gotta deliver it on time it's a
it's a it's a simpler way of doing it
and we keep in tune with their regime
and our routine so I you know my view is
that that would work very well I think
we're up for organizing that the man
from the Prison Service he say yes
my next challenge find a major retailer
to stop the slice so I can scale up
production